-As coronavirus cases
continue to surge
in states across the country
President Trump has been
quietly continuing
his all-out assault
on the environment,
so we decided to take a brea
from the breaking news
of the day
to see how Trump is taking
advantage of a global crisis
to make things even worse
for vulnerable Americans.
This is "The Check-In."
♪♪♪♪
[ Bell dings ]
President Trump has been
a colossal failure
at the one thing Americans are
most desperate for him to do -
contain the coronavirus.
He hasn't increased testing.
He hasn't dealt
with the economic fallout
and you could be forgiven
for thinking
he hasn't been doing
anything at all.
However, he has been
very successful
at rolling back
environmental regulations
and weakening
major conservation laws,
all while Americans
have been distracted
by a global pandemic
because, instead of pullin
back on pollution
when lungs are having
their worst year
since "Mad Men"
went off the air,
Trump has actually been doubling
down on his dangerous agenda
According to reports...
It's when Trump seems
to be doing nothing
that he's at his most dangerous.
It's like when your kids
are upstairs
and they're super quiet
for way too long.
You know you're
about to wallpaper
over some Sharpie.
That is not the path
of a hurricane, Tyler!
But, of course, whenever
Trump does something quietly
it's only because everything
else he's doing is so, so loud
that it seems quiet in relation.
Trump can't be quiet.
He'd be a terrible ninja.
[ As Trump ]
I came through the window.
You probably didn't hear m
because I'm quiet like the wind.
That's what my
karate master told me.
Even worse, Trump is using
the coronavirus pandemic,
which has disproportionately
affected people of color,
to push through
anti-science policies
under the guise
of creating more jobs,
jobs that rare rarely go
to the people most hurt
by these policies.
-Air pollution is linked
to higher
coronavirus death rates,
along with many
other health problems
and air pollution
is usually worse
in areas with larger
minority populations.
-The folks with the smallest
carbon footprints
are the ones who will feel
the most pain.
-We have just been beat down
People are devastated.
I don't think anybody's
life is worth a job.
-If people of color
and low income
who are most affected
by the issues
are never in the rooms
where the decisions
are being made,
we are going to continue
to have two different worlds
two different realities.
-No surprise
that Trump doesn't care
what happens to people of color,
but he also doesn't believ
it's happening at all,
as evidenced by this tweet
from 2014, when Trump wrote...
In fact, Trump's view
that global warming is a hoa
is one of the only stances
he's been consistent on.
That, and there's no such thin
as a tie that's too long.
[ As Trump ]
I like it to just
brush the top of the knee.
For example, he repeated
his same bizarre claims,
sprinkled with some
self-aggrandizement,
at the last G7 summit,
when a reporter questioned
Trump's skepticism
about climate change.
-In a nutshell,
I want the cleanest
water on Earth.
I want the cleanest air
on Earth.
And that's what we're doing.
And I'm an environmentalist.
A lotta people
don't understand that.
I have done more environmental
impact statements, probably,
than anybody that's --
I guess I can say definitely
'cause I've done many,
many, many of them --
more than anybody that's eve
been president or vice president
or anything even close
to president.
-You can't claim you're
an environmentalist
just because you look
like a compost heap.
Also, what do you mean you'v
done more on the environment
than anybody that's even
been close to president?
You know you're not close
to president, right,
you're there?
I mean, Al Gore was close
to president
and he, at least, made a ful
movie about the environment.
I should note, if there wa
a movie with Trump,
"A Convenient Lie"
would be a good title.
[ As Trump ]
Did I write a check
to Stormy Daniels?
You know, if I did,
I don't remember it.
But, of course,
Trump doesn't
actually want
clean air and water.
In fact, one of his
first actions
he took as president
proved that.
In early 2017,
he signed an executive order
to start the process
of repealing
an Obama era
clean water regulation
known as the Waters
of the United States rule.
The rule limited
the amount of pollution
that developers and landowners
could dump into our waterway
and Trump's repeal, which
environmentalists called a..
...was finalized less
than a year ago.
And, in the last few weeks
Trumped bragged about that
at two separate events, whil
telling the same weird story
about how people were allegedl
so overwhelmed with emotio
because of his actions.
-We stopped
the egregious abuse
of the Clean Water Act.
When I signed that legislation
I had many farmers
and construction people
standing behind me,
people that haven't cried
since they were a baby,
some of them never
even when they were a baby
and they were crying.
We did the U.S. waters.
You saw that.
The U.S. waters act.
That was a big one.
Grown men that had never cried
even when they were a baby
they were standing behind me
when I signed that bill
at the White House
and they were crying.
They were crying because w
gave their life back to 'em.
-For all the lying
Trump does,
you'd think he'd get
a little better at it.
All you did was sign
an order.
Why are you acting like
a revival tent preacher?
[ As Trump ]
I healed
her husband's rotted leg
and, oh!
How she cried and thanked me
Oh! She was more tears
than woman, she was.
And also, nobody was crying.
Check it out.
[ Camera shutters
clicking continuously ]
-Huge.
-Very.
-It's huge!
-Thank you.
-Maybe he mistook
that guy sweating
and thought
his neck was crying.
Why does he say some
of them never cried
even when they were babies
I mean, even for a weird man
that is a weird detail to add.
It really hammers home
what a egomaniac what he is.
It's not enough to make
someone cry like a baby.
He has to make them cry
for the first time
in their lives.
[ As Trump ]
I turned them from Data
into Dawson.
And, yeah, that is
back-to-back nights
referencing a show
that went off the air in 2003.
Either way, the truth
doesn't stop Trump
from using
that ridiculous anecdote
to promote yet another harmful
initiative gutting the...
It's a 50-year-old
conservation law
that requires federal agencies
to take into consideration
the environmental impact
of infrastructure projects
before they're approved.
Everything from how it
would affect local wildlif
to projected
greenhouse gas emissions.
It also allowed residents
to weigh in on the plans.
But, now, public review
would be limited, in order to...
And, once again, Trump use
the coronavirus as cover
for why something like thi
needs to be implemented.
And, look,
I think we can all agree
we need better roads
and bridges.
But I don't think Trumps wants
the roads to be better.
He just wants them
to be straighter.
-There's a highway
in a certain state,
short road --
not even a highway, I guess,
more of a roadway --
and they put in --
It was a straight line
from point to point.
By the time they finished it
18 years later,
it was this...
It cost tens of times --
it cost many, many, many times
more than the original.
It's a dangerous roadway
because there's turns.
You gotta be in good shape
You gotta be wide awake
to make those turns.
You gotta see those things
You have to see the guardrails
Bumm.
-I can't believe
I have to say this,
but you should be wide awake
when you drive,
no matter how many turns
there are on the roads.
[ As Trump ]
Under Trump, our roads
are gonna be so straight,
you can daydream and even
doze off in some places.
Also, he thinks you have
to be in good shape
to be able to turn
a steering wheel?
That might explain
the shape he's in.
He thinks driving to the gym
is the workout.
"Alright. Made it!
Time to hit the showers!"
Now, by ignoring
the environmental effects
of major construction projects
Trump is, once again,
harming communities
that have already been
much worse off
throughout his presidency.
Critics point out
that these new rules...
And, if it wasn't clear
before this,
the differences
between the two choices
we have in November
couldn't be more obvious.
For example,
the same week Trump touted
his pollution-permitting
proposals,
Joe Biden announced
his clean energy plans.
-Joe Biden announcing
his own plan
to invest $2 trillion
over four years
on clean jobs
and infrastructure.
-These investments are
a win-win-win for this country
creating jobs,
cutting energy costs,
protecting our climate.
When Donald Trump thinks
about climate change,
the only word he can muste
is "hoax."
I think about climate change
the word I think of is "jobs."
-He's right.
The work we need to do
to slow climate change wil
create thousands of new jobs
like building solar panels
and wind farms.
The problem with a president
like Trump is
that everyone he knows
and is beholden to
got rich on old jobs, like coa
mining and oil pipelines
and invading Ukraine.
The Trump presidency
will be over, someday,
but the sad reality is tha
the environmental effects
will be permanent
and that becomes
everyone's problem because
if we don't start taking
climate change seriously
and making major changes,
we're all gonna be crying
like babies,
even if we never cried lik
babies, in the first place
I wanna make that point.
That's a very important
point to add.
Not everyone cried
when they were a baby.
This has been
"The Check-In."
♪♪♪♪
[ Bell dings ]